they climbed the steps where just two
weeks ago
rioters stormed the capitol walked the
halls where they spread fear
ladies and gentlemen the president-elect
of the united states
joseph robinette biden jr and dr jill
biden
and took the oath of office where they
tried to overturn democracy
the riot not forgotten in this u.s
presidential inauguration
like no other two weeks ago when an
angry
violent mob stage and insurrection and
desecrated this temple of our democracy
it awakened us to our responsibilities
as americans protected by tens of
thousands of soldiers and police
a pandemic raging the thousands of usual
spectators replaced by flags
the dignitaries spaced out history was
made
the first african-american of south
asian descent
and the first woman to become vice
president
and then just before noon joe biden
became the new president
of the united states so help me god
congratulations mr president
the chaos of what happened here
remembered just days after a riotous mob
thought they could use violence to
silence the will of the people
to stop the work of our democracy to
drive us from this sacred ground
it did not happen it will never happen
not today not tomorrow not ever
mixing hope with the dark reality of
this moment
he pledged to be honest with the
american people and he laid out
a challenging agenda the dream of
justice for all
will be deferred no longer
a cry for survival comes from planet
itself
a cry that can't be any more desperate
or any more clear and now
a rise of political extremism white
supremacy
domestic terrorism that we must confront
and we will defeat this was a rebuke of
the last four years of president donald
trump
not mentioned by name trump was also not
in the audience peppered with past
presidents
only the fourth president to refuse to
attend but the very first
to refuse to concede he left washington
with only a small group to see him leave
impeached twice and facing a trial in
the senate for the riot he inspired
he's reportedly talking about creating
his own political party
to mount a political comeback so just
a goodbye we love you
we will be back in some form a true sign
of how much has changed
the biggest celebrities who shunned
trump's inaugural
[Music]
return to washington
[Music]
to celebrate a new president
the pandemic and security concerns meant
traditions needed to be changed
after the ceremony the new president and
vice president flanked by their
predecessors
laid a wreath at the tomb of the unknown
soldier at arlington national cemetery
and the parade was more of a televised
motorcade
but the traditional walk still happened
down pennsylvania avenue
and into the white house
their new home and now his oval office
patti culhane al jazeera